[Music]
there's always like limits you have to
respect on wherever especially in the
Middle East it can't be completely free
[Music]
when I vote it's like I'm expressing
myself like fully without no
restrictions whatsoever so I can just be
me
[Music]
I have a minister at home they're my
babies
I'm studying veterinary medicine but I
also have like this artistic side of me
I'm the voguing fabulous that let's say
that
[Music]
Bader's sweetly so crazy cuz there's a
lot of cultures going there a lot of
politics religions there's specific
places in bare boobs or accepting but
there's other places in Beirut where you
cannot be who you are you might get
attacked I try not to think of that
because you know it's just too
problematic and I don't have time for
that to be honest I'm I'm too busy
building my life in my career to think
about politics politics is [ __ ] to
me I don't like it let's talk about it
[Music]
voguing is a dance style that was
created by the LGBTQ people of color
back in the 80s in New York City I was
treated as a safe space for these people
to be themselves and express themselves
are being judged by other people it all
started like just practicing at home
having fun and just learning over
YouTube because you know there's no
purpose in lemon whatsoever I stopped
practicing every single day for like
three hours in my room Oh anywhere I can
I would just practice every day and then
I start posting videos on social media
and I start growing bigger and bigger
I think it's something very me and I
love to teach it to people and I would
love to spread this culture to other
people because it's a beautiful culture
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
on Friday I'm having a performance in a
club called project so project is like
the most accepting LGBTQ Club so yeah
everyone goes there just to have fun and
be for you I've been preparing with my
dancers and the outfits and everything
so I'm panicking I'm always panicking
this club is fully crowded every Friday
you have no idea and you have like
hundreds of people there so there's
gonna be a big show it's gonna be really
amazing people do not like feminine
stuff especially like for example gay
people they would prefer masculine
people got their kind of discreet and
they think like being feminine is is
just having fun and being silly or
whatever bring such a culture which is
very queer it's not straight at all it's
not masculine as a culture needs a lot
of hard work and show people it's
something fun once you're like fully
dressed with the makeup and everything
it's just who you are it's so great you
feel like oh this is my moment to shine
[Music]
dancing as ultimate freedom its life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
once I'm dancing I'm charging myself
again to face the world to me it's not a
problem being queer or being like
different than anyone else I'm just me
and take it or leave it
[Music]